et oui François oui 40
ans 40 ans 40 ans de combat commun 40
ans de de valeurs
partagées de là où nous
étions 40 ans
d'humanisme 40 ans
d'altruisme 40 ans à essayé de faire
prospérer les valeurs auxquel vous
croyez tous chez chers amis sénateur
Hervé député
Jean-Paul parlementaire européen
Marie-Pierre Christophe et tous les
autres et tous ceux qui sont là qui
donnent leur temps pour l'intérêt
général mais aussi pour pour nos valeurs
et c'est bien de ça dont je vais vous
parler dans le contexte dans le contexte
européen alors évidemment
cette dernière université d'été j' un
congrès mais avant des échéances très
importantes la prochaine dans un an on
saura quel est le nouveau Parlement
européen et sans
doute qui sera quels seront ceux celles
et ceux qui composeront le nouvel
exécutif
européen donc merci François de m'avoir
invité pour précisément parler de ça
parce que ce qui se passe devant nous va
être très important puis on aura plus
tellement l'occasion de le faire dans en
tout cas cet environnement et dans ce
contexte
et moi je voudrais vous dire d'abord une
chose si il y a vraiment une famille
politique une famille politique qui sait
nouer les partenariats parce qu'elle
s'intéresse aux autres c'est la
nôtre on parle évidemment d'humanisme
mais c'est vrai que nous on sait ce que
c'est que de créer des consensus et on
travaille en consensus et pourquoi on
travaille en consensus parce que on est
fort sur nos convictions plus on est
fort sur nos convictions meilleur on est
dans l'établissement de consensus pour
aller trouver précisément le cheminement
pour aller pour aller de l'avant alors
évidemment maintenant on en a batti des
consensus croyez-moi et nos
parlementaires européens le savent
d'abord ils le font moi en tant que
commissaire européen donc
l'exécutif je rappelle que notre
exécutif il est le fruit d'un d'un
consensus de quatre familles politiques
le PPE mais socidémocrate renew notre
famille européenne et les Verts et
derrière il faut se faire entendre
respecter évidemment les positions des
uns et des autres trouver les chemins
communs il y a un temps pour tout il y a
un temps pour l'action politique et
c'est ce que j'ai fait commissaire
européen c'est exercer une action
politique pour porter vos valeurs nos
valeurs au sein de l'exécutif européen
et c'est ce que j'ai fait dans tous les
les domaines dont j'ai eu la charge j'
Rai dans un instant parce que je crois
qu'il faut parler aussi de ce bilan mais
qui est le bilan renew qui est le bilan
modemme ce bilan il appartient à
personne d'autre et par parenthèse et
par parenthèse puisque nous rentrons
désormais dans cette nouvelle phase de
notre vie politique on va être dans nos
tunnels pour quelques
mois le moment des consensus de
l'intermédiation est terminé il s'agit
maintenant de gagner sur nos valeurs et
de faire comprendre à nos concitoyens
que c'est elles qui nous permettront
précisément de faire révonner et nos
valeurs et aussi ce que nous sommes nous
Français au sein de l'exécutif européen
donc
oui on a pas besoin on a plus
besoin d'avoir un tel ou un tel qui vont
venir intermédier non on n pas besoin
non plus d'avoir un tel ou un tel pour
dire que notre bilan est tellement
solide et tellement fort que nous
n'avons pas peur d'affronter
le rassemblement national et les
extrêmes et on a besoin de personne pour
se faire notre seul
bilan nos valeurs notre vision aussi
pour l'avenir
suffiront alors quelques éléments de ce
que nous avons fait au cours des qu
dernières années de ce que j'ai fait en
votre nom à tous au fond au cours des qu
dernières années évidemment en poussant
l'agenda du président de la République
notamment le fameux discours de la
avec l'autonomie stratégique mais pas
que mais pas que marieierre mais pas que
Christophe on reviendra mais évidemment
grâce à l'action gouvernemental Mar
jeannoël et tous les autres bien sûr au
soutien sans faille sans faille ce qui
est pas toujours chose
courante par les temps qui cour en
politique et du groupe au Sénat HERV et
du groupe à
l'Assemblée donc au fond je voulais
juste indiquer que en ce qui me concerne
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à à ce que à ce
qu'on a fait au fond au des qu dernières
années et comment l'Europe a basculé et
je crois pouvoir vous dire que si je
retiens un
mot de cette action et de l'action au
fond de ce mandat de 5 ans qui va
s'agever dans quelques mois c'est
l'émergence du conceptte de la notion
d'Europe puissance quand je dis Europe
puissance ça veut pas dire arrogance ça
veut pas dire écraser les autres ça veut
dire prendre conscience que c'est parce
que nous sommes tous unis les 27 450
millions de concitoyens européens que
nous pouvons d'abord mettre sur pied
bâtir les politiques qui nous protège
mais aussi qui font que on peut se faire
entendre dans le monde tel qu'il est
vous l'avez rappelé admirablement bien
ce monde de bloc ce monde au fond où ce
qui change de plus en plus c'est la
notion de rapport de force mais qui dit
rapport de force veut dire que
évidemment il faut qu'on soit conscient
de nos forces Europe puissance Europe
puissance je l'ai vécu dans beaucoup de
domaines d'abord toutes les politiques
que j'ai porté en notre nom que ce soit
dans l'industrie que ce soit dans le
numérique Jean reviendrai que ce soit
dans la défense ou dans l'espace
Christophe que ce soit en ce qui
concerne la défense de l'État de droit
de nos valeurs que ce soit dans le fait
de pousser une politique africaine tout
ce que nous avons
porté je tiens à dire ça a été initié
par notre famille politique et au
début combien j'ai eu de retrait non non
non faut pas y aller comment Thierry tu
veux parler de nucléaire mais non non
non non on n pas le droit de parler de
nucléaire à la Commission européenne oui
mais on en a besoin pour la
décarbonation on en a besoin pour le
Green Deal on en a besoin pour le pacte
vert ah non non on parle plus de
nucléaire alors si vous voulez bien
parlons d'énergie de transition
décarboné ah oui al ça on peut d'accord
voilà voilà qu'elle a été mon quotidien
pendant 4 ans pour faire en sorte que
l'on puisse se faire entendre progresser
évoluer pas à pas et faire émerger cette
notion d'Europe puissance la fin de la
naiveté le monde change l'Europe doit
s'adapter alors la premre
des chocs parce que évidemment on a vécu
un nombre de chocs quasiment
incalculable l'un après l'autre bien sûr
on a tous en tête le choc du covid la
covid et les vaccins une Europe au début
totalement désorientée on savait plus où
on habita les frontières se
fermaient m'a confié la responsabilité
tu t'en souviens François de reprendre
les choses en main avec un esprit aussi
d'entrepreneur et en l'espace de
quelques mois qui le CR nous avons
réussi à faire en sorte que l'Europe
devienne parce que nous nous sommes
unis l'usine du monde en matière de
vaccination notamment à REM messager
personne l'aurait cru 52 usines qu'on a
remonté au niveau pour faire face à ces
défis et puis aussi nos valeurs et
croyez-moi que je les ai poussé non nous
on fait pas ça uniquement pour nos
concitoyens on le fait aussi pour les
autres à un moment où les
États-Unis ferm leurs frontières avec ce
qu'on appelle un DPA qu'ils
interdisaient tout simplement non
seulement l'exportation de vaccins
America First c'était par parenthèse pas
Donald Trump c'était Joe
Biden on interdisait toutes les chaînes
de valeur de fonctionner plus même si
c'était nos usines combien de réunions
j'ai dû tenir avec la Maison Blanche
pour dire mais c'est mes usines Jef
sence c'était le US chief vaccine il est
maintenant le directeur de cabinet de
Biden chef c'est mes usines c'est nos
usines européennes ah oui Thierry mais
on a une interdiction c'est pour les
Américains d'abord oui mais c'est nos
usines non non c'est comme ça donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait Europe puissance
j'uris dû convaincre mes collègues du
collège qu'il fallait aussi que nous
prenions des mesures pour faire en sorte
que si on ne mettait pas en place la
réciprocité et bien nous aussi on se
comporterait de cette façon et devinez
quoi la semaine d'après lorsque j'ai
annoncé dans mes entretien hebdomadaire
à Jeff Z que non je pouvais pas lui
envoyer de lipide parce queon on avait
mis un place un outil de réciprocité il
m'a dit mais c'est du chantage Thierry
je su dit oui c'est du chantage mais tu
sais très bien ce qu'il t'incombe de
faire pour réouvrir les chaînes de
valeur la semaine d'après tout
refonctionner rapidement l'Europe
puissance mais l'Europe puissance aussi
en ce qui concerne les conséquences les
conséquences juste une parenthèse on a
quand même pendant cette période fourni
les vaccins à 112 pays de la planète 112
tous les pays de l'OTAN ont été vaccinés
par nous tous les pays de l'OTAN lorsque
je vais en Corée et qu'on me dit quand
même les Américains ont été formidables
oui mais c'est les Européens qui ont
fourni les vaccins ah d'accord pareil au
Japon c'est aussi notre fierté c'est
aussi un peu l'exemple que nous donnons
de notre comportement mais pour se faire
Europe puissance aussi Europe puissance
en ce qui concerne l'énergie quand il a
fallu réagir aussi rapidement face à
cette guerre terrible voulue par
Vladimir Poutine euh en Ukraine et
évidemment l'utilisation qu'il fait de
toutes nos dépendances pour pouvoir nous
affaiblir en les utilisant comme comme
des armes contre notre projet et contre
nous Europe
puissance lorsque pour accompagner la
transition numérique sergent Noël qui
nous est si cher mais aussi la
transition verte climatique qui est si
importante on s'est rendu compte que
c'était pas non plus quelque chose qui
était méconnu de tous et bien qu'il
fallait des smiconducteurs il fallait
des semiconducteurs en Europe et qu'on
est en train de perdre cette course là
très vite on a mis sur pied ce qu'on
appelle le le chip Act européen eu chip
Act ça a été une révolution faire en
sorte que pour la première fois dans
notre histoire on change les règles de
concurrence on change les règles de
politique industrielle pour pouvoir
bâtir ensemble un projet global attirer
les entreprises qui voudraient venir
produire en Europe on était passé de 40
% de production en 2000 à 9 % en
2022 alors qu'on sait que si jamais 50 %
de ces semiconducteurs sont produits
vous le savez tous dans la rivière des
Perles et à taiïwan les frontièr se
fermer pour les raisons géopolitiques
que tout le monde a en tête ce serait 15
jours maximum avant que toutes les
usines européennes ferm et bien nous
l'avons fait nous l'avons porté nous
avons réussi à mobiliser 43 milliards
d'euros on a aujourd'hui 100 milliards
d'euros de projets 67 usines et projets
aujourd'hui qui sont en construction en
Europe c'est ça aussi l'Europe puissance
mais l'Europe puissance c'est la même
chose en ce qui
concerne ce qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon la cleantetech c'est-à-dire
l'équivalent de ce qui est nécessaire
pour notre industrie numérique avec les
industries qui sont les industries qui
contribuent à la décarbonation parce que
bien sûr c'est vrai et nous en sommes
fiers nous avons réussi à proposer la
régulation les régulations les plus
performantes les plus ambitieuses pour
atteindre la décarbonation en 2050 c'est
la fierté de l'Europe bien sûr
mais comme on le disait avec René moneri
François la stratégie c'est bien
l'exécution c'est mieux et maintenant on
est dans l'exécution et ce sera du rest
dans l'exécution qu'on sera
pour les 5 ans qui viennent et c'est la
capacité de démontrer qu'on est dans
cette exécution juste en ne laissant
personne sur le bord de la
route que ce soit nos concitoyens que ce
soit un pays que ce soit une industrie
que ce soit une PME c'est ça l'un des
objectifs majeurs qui est devant nous
désormais et pour se faire il fallait
aussi avoir des nouveaux actes
législatifs ça été l'acte législatif euh
Christophe sur les matériaux critiques
on a fait très vite une cartographie 37
matériaux critiques qui sont
indispensable du cobalt au manganaise en
passant par le lithium les terres rares
le germanium toutes ces terres rares
tous ces composants qui sont seulement
essentiels à notre transition climatique
on en a en Europe mais on dépend
évidemment massivement des autres en
particulier de la Chine il est temps là
aussi de reprendre son destin en main
nous l'avons fait avec
le CRMA le critical raw material Act et
y compris en accompagnant par les
alliances des filières hydrogène des
filières batteries mais aussi des
filières panneaux photovoltaïque on a vu
ce que le laxisme et la naïveté
pouvaient nous conduire à laisser faire
en Chine 95 % du marché qui est parti
là-bas évidemment les batteries les
véhicules électriques j'en passe et des
meilleurs sans oublier l'avion
décarponné zéro émission tout ça c'est
effectivement le comment c'est bien la
politique mais la politique c'est
l'exécution l'exécution avec nos valeurs
l'exécution sans oublier personne c'est
aussi se défendre c'est aussi se
défendre parce que évidemment évidemment
une Europe puissance c'est une Europe
qui sait se défendre par elle-même et
qui n'attend pas en permanence je ne
sais quel parapluie pour dire que il
nous protègera tout jamais je me
souviens de cette réunion en janvier
2020 alors que j'acompagnais Van derlen
m'avait demandé de l'accompagner parce
que je connais un petit peu les
États-Unis comme tu sais François et on
avait un rendez-vous notre premier
rendez-vous avec Donald Trump président
des États-Unis d'Amérique il commence la
Réunion en lui disant pardon je parl en
en anglais avec un accent
texll c'était comme ça que la réunion a
commencé alors Ursula qui n'a pas
exactement le même gabarit que Donald
Trump je l'ai vu encore s'enfoncer dans
sa chaise il la prenait pour uniquement
une Allemande c'est vrai queand est
allemande mais il il ne voyait qu'une
allemande et donc l'Allemagne lui devait
400 milliards d'euros parce que
l'Allemagne n'avait pas payé sa
contribution à l'OTAN et que donc tant
que l'Allemagne ne prait pas il lui a
dit je vais refuser maintenant de
soutenir on va sortir de l'OTAN c'était
il y a 4 ans c'était le président des
États-Unis d'Amérique l'UTAN n'existe
plus dit-il ça c'était il y a 4
ans j'ai cru comprendre que les
prochaines élections
américaines tout était encore ouvert ne
l'oublions pas ne l'oublions pas et donc
pour nous qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
accélérer évidemment accélérer d'abord
la maîtrise de notre outil de défense on
a fait avec le Fond Européen de défense
c'est formidable on on contrôle et on
maîtrise toutes les technologies de
défense en Europe tu le sais vraiment
notre ami ministre lodrian qui a été un
très grand ministre de la Défense je
peux un témoignage ici très grand
ministre d' affaires étrangères on a
tellement bien travaillé ensemble
tellement bien
travaillé et alors là
aussi François avec Jean yy c'est depuis
81 qu'on chemine ensemble
81 tu le sais on a donc réussi à bâtir
ce Fond Européen de défense on maîtrise
toutes les technologies tous les
savoir-faires en défense en Europe le
problème c'est qu'il nous faut 4 an
souvent sa c'est un peu un mal français
mais Monsieur le Commissaire je sais
tout faire je sais faire des missiles
hyper onique je vais faire des smarins
nucléaaires je sais faire des chars je
sais faire des des obus téléguidés je
sais faire des avion formidable quel
délai 3 4 ans mais c'est la meilleure
technologie du monde d'accord mais il y
a la guerre sur le continent il y a la
guerre sur le continent et donc le sujet
maintenant c'est d'augmenter nos
capacités et d'augmenter nos outils
notre outils de production et c'est
précisément ce que nous avons fait avec
notamment les programmes qu'on en a
déployé azap en particulier pour la
première fois de notre histoire on met
de l'argent et on a fait voter ça à
combien au Parlement européen 80 % 85 %
90 % du Parlement européen Bernard qui a
soutenu notre proposition renew ah oui
que vous voulez qui était de dire il
faut aussi qu'on accélère la base
industrielle la capacité de production
de notre outil industriel tout
simplement parce qu'il faut qu'on
fournisse effectivement au peuple
ukraénien ce dont il a besoin on s'est
engagé sur un million de munitions une
capacité 1 million de munitions mais
aussi ne soyons pas naïfs parce que dans
la guerre qui se déroule où
effectivement ce sont nos valeurs qui
sont en jeu et que le peuple ukrainien
défend aussi ne l'oublion jamais ne
l'oublions jamais dans ce rapport de
force là sur le front est euh il y a une
chose aussi que comprendreadim la seule
le rapport de force alors je le dis
sincèrement mon objectif à moi qui suis
aussi le commissaire en charge de la
défense c'est qu'on a une capacité
industrielle qui soit égale ou
supérieure à celle de la Russie car
c'est la seule chose qu'il comprendra y
compris si un jour nous devions avoir
faire avoir faire seul face à notre
destin c'est la seule chose et je prends
l'engagement devant vous quand 2 ans ce
sera fait et ça c'est grâce encore une
fois au Parlement européen au Conseil
européen et la
capacité de négociation de créer des
consensus de votre commissaire et de
l'équipe qui l'entoure mais l'UR
puissance c'est aussi la régulation de
l'espace informationnel Jean Noël et là
poussé par la France et je tiens à
remercier et à saluer l'action de la
France et du président de la République
sur cette question mais croyez-moi je
m'en suis occupé tu le sais que c'est un
sujet qui m'intéresse depuis plusieurs
décennies François ça a été mon premier
travail dès le premier jour et
voyez-vous on a commencé on s'est dit il
y a un marché unique il est
toujours en progression mais il y a pas
de marché unique de la donnée du
numérique et c'est bien ça notre
problème il est trop fragmenté donc on a
mis en place une première régulation qui
est une régulation pour enfin dire aux
plateformes dans l'espace
informationnel ce n'est plus une zone de
non droit vous n'avez plus tous les
droits vous avez une responsabilité
c'est le DSA dans l'espace
informationnel c'est pas parce que vous
êtes gros que vous avez tous les droits
et en particulier un droit d'éviction ou
un droit de monopole c'est le DMA dans
l'espace informationnel il y a des
problèmes de cybersécurité j'arrive et
donc désormais on fait une cybersécurité
par design on met aussi on travaille sur
un bloc aussi un cyber bouclier qu'on
appelle cybers shield pour protéger
notre espace informationnel dans
l'espace informationnel on peut créer
aussi maintenant des applications
extraordinaires mais aussi les pires
avec l'intelligence artificielle et donc
on a bâti on est en train de finaliser
on a encore deux trilogues et ce sera
fini donc le trilogue qui nous permettra
de d'avoir la première régulation au
monde pas très agressif basé sur les
risques et
voyez-vous il faut avoir un peu de pris
des coups dans la vie on en a pris
quelquesuns François pour mener ces
combats parce que ces combats j'ai dû
les mener contre tout le monde contre
les plateformes contre les lobbies ils
sont 1350 à Bruxelles contre beaucoup
d'états-membres contre nos alliés et
notamment les États-Unis d'Amérique qui
ont tout fait pour qu'on ne le fasse pas
et on a réussi à le faire Europe
puissance on a réussi à le faire et là
encore une dernière petite une dernière
petite euh anecdote il y a 15 jours la
numéro 2 du Département d'État aux
États-Unis vient me voir et elle me dit
euh commissaire on voudrait vous dire
merci bon merci au nom des États-Unis
d'Amérique ah bon mais très bien merci
d'avoir mis en place le DSA et le DMA
parce que c'est très important pour
l'Europe c'est très important pour les
États-Unis c'est très important pour le
monde nos amis américains sont
pragmatiques lorsque l'Europe puissance
s'affirme dans l'intérêt général même si
au début c'est chaotique à la fin il le
reconnîent l'Europe puissance et je
terminerai Christophe évidemment l'UR
puissance avec l'espace parce qu'on peut
pas oublier l'espace l'espace
est une zone contesté tellement
importante avec ce qu'on fait avec
Galileo avec ce qu'on fait avec
Copernicus mais avec ce qu'on a décidé
de faire aussi c'est c'était pas prévu
au budget Bernard quand on a lancé iris
j'avais pas de budget et ben on l'a
trouvé on a trouvé un budget pour pour
bâtir la constellation la plus avancée
au monde en matière de connectivité de
connectivité qui nous permet d'avoir des
des moyens de connexion sécurisé partout
en Europe dans toutes les zones blanches
pour les particuliers mais aussi pour
les gouvernements de surveiller l'espace
par l'espace et également d'offrir à nos
amis africains parce que c'est des
constellations dans leur bit bass Nord
sudud d'offrir de la connectivité
surtout le continent africain
gratuitement pour faire en sorte que
l'Afrique nous rejoigne aussi dans
l'espace informationnel et c'est mon
dernier point que nous ayons enfin une
vraie politique africaine non plus État
par État mais continent par continent et
c'est indispensable ce sera un enjeu
majeur de la prochaine commission majeur
avoir une politique africaine globale
unifié de toute l'Union on est le
premier contributeur en Afrique avec
notre programme global Gateway le
premier de très loin par rapport aux
Chinois par rapport aux Turcs je parle
même pas par rapport aux Russes qui font
rien que désinformés mais il faut le
faire savoir il faut accompagner ce sera
un enjeu majeur pour cette population
jeune ce sera un un enjeu majeur pour le
développement ce sera un enjeu majeur
aussi pour les migration et les
politiques migratoires on le sait voilà
donc en quelques mots ce que je voulais
dire dans notre bilan en ce qui nous
concerne pour l'avenir il faut renforcer
coûte que coûte cette et inscrire dans
le marbre cette autonomie stratégique
dont je viens de décrire les contours
finalement autour de ma présentation
l'inscrire dans le marbre de façon
pragmatique faire en sorte que on
accompagne la transition verte faire en
sorte que l'on puisse développer ce
concept de sécurité économique qui
désormais fait partie aussi de nos
outils y compris avec la Chine sans être
aligné évidemment avec les États-Unis en
trouvant notre voie Europe puissance
c'est aussi évidemment renforcer notre
rôle
d'acteurs géopolitique bien sûr dans le
cadre des enjeux que je viens de décrire
mais aussi en ce qui concerne
l'élargissement parce que bien entendu
on n dupe de rien on sait parfaitement
que en ce qui concerne le conflit en
Ukraine on se prépare à ce que celui-ci
dure à ce que nous prenions une charge
de plus en plus importante je rappelle
qu'on est à peu près à 80 85 milliards
d'euros de soutien équivalent même un
peu supérieur à celui des États-Unis
d'Amérique je tiens à le dire parce que
je lis souvent l'inverse mais au fond
derrière ce qui se passera c'est que
dans les discussions que nous espérons n
vux c'est pas la peine de lire des
livres d'ex-président de la République
c'est pas la peine
je écoutez plutôt ce que disent vos
députés européens écoutez plutôt ce que
disent vos experts écoutez ce que disent
Bernard ce sera plus utile et sans doute
plus près de la réalité et cette réalité
c'est que seuls les ukrainiens et les
Russes vont décider du moment de la
table de négociation et personne d'autre
mais il faudra être à leur côté en
soutien démontrer que on est sérieux et
donc peut-être aussi accélérer
l'intégration de l'Ukraine à l'Europe
puisque je vous rappelle que désormais
nous sommes en train de l'étudier avec
évidemment derrière avec évidemment tout
ce que ça veut dire sur le l'ensemble de
l'élargissement et avec ce qui se passe
j'anive en ce moment même dans les
Balcans et notamment occidentaux qui est
un autre foyer sur lequel je vous invite
à regarder très attentivement et qui ne
me réjouit pas vous pouvez vous en être
conscient et vous en rendre compte voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire aujourd'hui
mes chers amis nous avons un bilan
formidable il est à votre disposition on
va maintenant travailler ensemble pour
le mettre en musique on va pas se le
faire voler hein parce qu'il nous
appartient mais de toute façon on le
partage hein mais c'est dans ce sens que
ça doit se faire de renouer de modem
vers les autres et pas l'inverse parce
que je sais parfaitement moi qui a fait
quoi et ça c'est très important que vous
en soyez également conscient altruisme
on va l'offrir aux autres mais rien des
autres on sait que comme d'habitude
François c'est ce qu'on a appris depuis
maintenant un siècle le destin c'est
nous qui devons le maîtriser qu'on
attend rien des autres mais parce que
nous sommes humanistes on sait que on
pourra élargir et donner notre
expérience l'offrir à ceux qui voudront
nous rejoindre je vous remercie